listen
up
Dan secrets on a whole another level God
I hate that cat so first question for
you guys it was awesome love the movie
um why should fans experience Argy on
IMAX dude why shouldn't they why I mean
it's it's the way to go yeah I mean it's
it's we're talking Matthew Vaughn
visuals here so it's big colors it's
extraordinary frames it's it's bigger
and Bolder than even they may expect so
IMAX is is the perfect thing to watch it
I mean for a 10-year-old 12-year-old kid
I mean it's like going to Raiders of the
Lost AR for the first time I mean maybe
that's a maybe that's a high you know
but it's it's a comparison but it's
really I think that's the kind of movie
it is you know yeah no and it feels that
way I think bigger Boulder IMAX should
be the new tagline so we go you just
came I will not give you that for free
the expecting commission um well it's
all yours why do you think fan should
experience our guy on IMAX there's no
bigger place for a bigger movie full
stop it's a big story that needs to be
seen on a big screen so theoretically
this is kind of digging into both your
fandoms if you could experience any
movie again or for the first time on an
IMAX screen what would it be and why
Star Wars Episode 4 Because by the way
it was like an IM I I was I was six when
that came out and it felt back then any
screen felt like NX you were six I was
six when it came out and I was and I
this how I know this why I know how
young I was is I thought Darth Vader was
in the smaller ship going up to get the
princess right because I assumed he was
the pirate and you were six I was six oh
my God yeah damn I bought a nickel bag
of weed and bottle of beer and went to
the stood in line and went into the
theater and jumped in hyper hypers space
yeah but i' grown I'm I'm sorry
I was grown you were six I was six oh my
God yeah and I rid that's when I fell in
love with movies yeah I me nothing like
you know this guy jumping in the
hyperspace is like come on but you you
had a light you have to do you yeah I
still have it's at home but I mean but
to sit in the theater he he said what
what movie you're right yeah episode
four jumping in the hypers space for the
first time it would be yeah that would
blow me away too I want to queue it up
for you guys now I just watch it with
you honestly I still my lightsaber at
home too
so nothing like a purple lightsaber if
you could experience any movie again or
for the first time in IMAX what would it
be in
why um Scarface G go with Scarface I've
never heard Scarface that's a great one
it's a good one that's pretty good it's
big film making you want to see big film
making and uh you know operatic film
making in an IMAX I love that gladiator
and or braveart oh yeah now you're
talking yeah that's a good call this
movie another thing about your fandom
this movie has a lot of twists and I'm
really curious I know there's so many
twists in movie history and you guys
have both been parts of great films is
there a specific movie twist that you
guys love or like call back to as just
fans uh well six cents obviously that's
a good one um I feel like I knew that
one was coming yeah all right you don't
have to brag about it no no but like I
was I remember being I remember being
surprised I was like you guys didn't
pick up on
that that's well you're he's a smart guy
my mom is the kind of person I'm very
gullible my mom has been ruining movies
since I was knee high to a grasshopper
she'd be like oh they're the killer
you're like what is she a writer no she
she just knows she she clearly has read
the scripts yeah you're ahead of it
you're ahead of it yeah not to say it
wasn't a great twist I'm saying I felt
like I all over the six sense
sorry six
sense um I want to ask you guys uh you
know there's so many visually stunning
sequences in this film um is there one
moment in particular that you think are
going to blow fans away in IMAX what do
you think I think the train sequence
where you two are both fighting and
we're I think train sequence is is is
extraordinary and will be extraordinary
in IMAX there's also a particularly
colorful sequence with lots of smoke
which we will not mention in too much
detail which I think will also be
incredible an IMAX yeah yeah I agree
those are great choices I did want to
ask about that sequence in the filming
of it um you know obviously you both had
to have done a lot of the same stuff for
it like I would love to kind of hear
your insights behind the scenes of that
and then seeing like what you guys
thought of the final version of that
sequence well I mean when we're
rehearsing that stuff because it's it's
a New Concept we had to we had to keep
on uh we shot the thing with the stunt
team and then they'd edit it together in
their own way and then Matthew would see
it then we Chang stuff and so we had a
vague idea
and the real work went into obviously
the stun team building thing in the
first place but then Sam and I trying to
uh match each other physically while
maintaining the individuality of our of
our characters sir you craft such
visually astonishing sequences in films
throughout your career and this film is
no exception like it blew my mind in
multiple ways and I'm just curious for
both of you is there a scene that you
think in particular is going to blow
people away in IMAX the wide shot of you
in the
vineyard helicop in the vard yeah that
would be
one TOS Tops on M yeah I think the ice
and the ice skating will look pretty
damn cool I think watch in the Lakers
game I was trying to figure out which
team it was to was
going